mais surtout le gouvernement s'est
contenté d'annoncer au coude annonce
mais peu d'actions il a fait le dos rond
en attendant que la vague passe mais
c'était mal nous connaître puisque parce
que nous sommes tenaces c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire est que nous pensons
sincèrement qu'il faut agir certes le
gouvernement a pris une circulaire le 19
janvier 2022 le même jour que l'audition
de la ministre de la transformation
public devant la commission denquête
faut noter quand même que ça ressemble à
une drôle de coïncidence qui continue
toujours de nous étonner mais cette
circulaire reste incomplète et elle
n'est pas contraignante pour
l'administration elle n'est selon une
formule qui me plaît beaucoup elle n'est
qu'un mur de papier face à un phénomène
bien plus large de recours généralisé au
cabinet de conseil
[Musique]